this is the site where a Yeti Airlines
flight carrying 72 people crashed in The
Nepalese tourist town of Pokhara
a search and Recovery team worked
through the day Monday to retrieve
bodies from deep within a narrow Gorge
the plane took off from Kathmandu less
than an hour later it came down near its
destination the newly opened Pokhara
International Airport it narrowly missed
homes on either side of the city Gorge
and river which runs through the town
it's tragic that we lost 72 people
aboard the plane but if it had crashed a
couple of meters on either side we would
have lost many more an army and police
recovery team has worked to retrieve
bodies and identified personal
belongings found in the wreckage
the plane was carrying 57 Nepalese and
15 foreign Nationals flying in Nepal is
challenging as the country is surrounded
by mountains and difficult Terrain in
the past the country has witnessed
numerous crashes early in the day a
search and Recovery team retrieved the
black box of the ill-fated Yeti Airlines
flight experts hope it will provide
answers to the tragedy tensions Run High
as families and relatives outside a
hospital wait to claim their loved ones
the brother-in-law of this Indian
businessman was on the plane Sanjay
jaiswal had traveled to the town to see
his older sister who had just had a baby
we'd like to do the last ride soon but
there was a lot of process and red tape
involved it's frustrating I'm waiting
hospital staff try to placate distressed
family members but they'll have to wait
at least another day before they can lay
their loved ones to rest ramyata limbu
Al Jazeera in Pokhara Nepal